con los materiales que conformarían la estructura,
con la ubicación de los cables y los tornillos.
Por suerte, no fui ingeniero espacial
sino arquitecto.
Estos son algunos de los proyectos en los que he participado
en la última década y media.
Todos estos proyectos son muy diferentes, con formas bastante diferentes,
y es porque están construidos para diferentes entornos.
Tienen diferentes restricciones.
Y creo que el diseño se pone realmente interesante
si hay restricciones realmente duras.
Estos son proyectos de todo el mundo.
Hace unos años, este mapa no era lo suficientemente bueno.
Era muy pequeño.
Tuvimos que agregar este,
porque íbamos a hacer un proyecto en la Luna
para la Agencia Espacial Europea;
nos pidieron que diseñáramos un hábitat lunar...
y uno en Marte con la NASA,
una competencia para diseñar una habitación en Marte.
Cada vez que vas a otro lugar,
como arquitecto
tratas de diseñar algo,
miras la arquitectura local, los precedentes que están allí.
Pero en la Luna, es un poco difícil, por supuesto,
porque solo hay esto.
Solo están las misiones Apollo.
La última vez que fuimos allí, yo ni siquiera había nacido aún,
y solo pasamos unos tres días allí.
Para mí, eso fue una especie de largo viaje de campamento, ¿no?,
aunque bastante caro.
Ahora, lo complicado,
si vas a construir en otro planeta o en una luna,
es cómo llegar allí.
Entonces antes que nada,
llevar un kilo, por ejemplo, a la superficie lunar,
costará unos USD 200 000,
algo muy costoso.
Y debe ser algo muy liviano.
Segundo, el espacio. El espacio es limitado, ¿sí?
Este es el cohete Ariane 5.
El espacio que tienes allí
es de unos 4.5 X 7 m, no mucho.
Debe ser un sistema arquitectónico
a la vez compacto, o compactable, y liviano,
y creo que tengo uno aquí.
Es muy compacto
y muy liviano.
Y, en realidad,
este es uno que hice antes.
Pero, hay un problema con eso,
y es que los inflables
son bastante frágiles
Deben estar protegidos,
sobre todo, en un entorno tan duro como el de la Luna.
Véanlo así.
La diferencia de temperatura en una base lunar
podría llegar a ser de 200 º.
En un lado de la base podría haber 100 °C
y en el otro lado, podría haber menos -100 °C.
Debemos protegernos de eso.
La Luna tampoco tiene campo magnético,
o sea que cualquier radiación -- sea solar o cósmica --
golpeará la superficie.
Debemos protegernos de eso también,
proteger a los astronautas de eso.
Y luego tercero,
pero definitivamente no último,
la Luna no tiene atmósfera,
o sea que cualquier meteorito que llegue a ella no se quemará,
impactará en la superficie.
Por eso la Luna está llena de cráteres.
Nuevamente, debemos proteger a los astronautas de eso.
Pero, ¿qué tipo de estructura necesitamos?
Lo mejor es realmente una cueva,
porque una cueva tiene mucha masa, y necesitamos masa.
Necesitamos masa para protegernos de las temperaturas,
de la radiación
y de los meteoritos.
Y lo resolvimos así.
De hecho, tenemos la parte azul, como pueden ver.
Es un inflable para nuestra base lunar.
Da mucho espacio de vida y mucho espacio de laboratorio,
y unido a eso hay un cilindro,
todo con las estructuras de soporte,
el soporte a la vida y también la cámara de aire.
Y además de eso, hay una estructura, esa estructura abovedada,
que nos protege,
y tiene mucha masa adentro.
¿De dónde vamos a obtener este material?
¿Vamos a llevar concreto y cemento de la Tierra a la Luna?
Claro que no, porque es demasiado pesado.
Es demasiado costoso.
Así que vamos a ir y usar materiales locales.
Pero también usamos materiales locales en la Tierra.
Donde sea que construyamos, en cualquier país que construyamos,
siempre buscamos los materiales locales.
El problema con la Luna es, ¿cuáles son los materiales locales?
Bueno, no hay tantos.
En realidad, hay uno.
Es polvo lunar,
o, su nombre científico más elegante, regolito, regolito lunar.
Lo bueno es que está en todas partes, ¿sí?
La superficie está cubierta de regolito.
Desde unos 20 cm hasta algunos metros por todos lados.
Pero, ¿cómo vamos a construir con eso?
Bueno, vamos a usar una impresora 3D.
Si le pregunto a alguno de Uds. qué es una impresora 3D,
quizá esté pensando, bueno, tal vez es algo de este tamaño
que imprimirá cosas de este tamaño.
Por supuesto que no voy a llevar a la Luna una impresora 3D enorme
para imprimir mi base lunar.
Voy a usar un dispositivo mucho más pequeño, algo como esto.
Este es un dispositivo pequeño, un pequeño robot,
que tiene una palita,
y trae el regolito al domo
después extiende una fina capa de regolito
y luego el robot la compactará,
capa por capa,
hasta crear, en unos meses,
la base completa.
Puede que hayan notado
que la estructura que estamos imprimiendo es bastante particular,
y aquí tengo un pequeño ejemplo.
La denominamos estructura de espuma de celda cerrada.
Parece bastante natural.
Y la usamos porque
como parte de esa estructura de caparazón
solo necesitamos solidificar ciertas partes,
y así debemos llevar menos aglutinante de la Tierra,
y se hace mucho más liviano.
Ahora...
ese enfoque de diseñar algo
para luego cubrirlo con un domo protector
también lo hicimos para nuestro proyecto de Marte.
Pueden verlo aquí, tres domos.
Y ven las impresoras que imprimen estas estructuras de domo.
Hay una gran diferencia entre Marte y la Luna,
y les explicaré.
Este diagrama muestra en escala
el tamaño de la Tierra y la Luna y la distancia real,
unos 400 000 km.
Si luego vamos a Marte,
la distancia de Marte a la Tierra...
y esta imagen
la toma el rover Curiosity en Marte, mirando hacia la Tierra.
Aquí ven un puntito, es la Tierra, a 400 millones de km de distancia.
El problema con esa distancia
es que es mil veces la distancia de la Tierra a la Luna es muy distante,
pero no hay contacto directo por radio con, por ejemplo, el rover Curiosity.
Entonces no lo puedo teleoperar desde la Tierra.
No puedo decir: "Rover de Marte, ve a la izquierda",
porque esa señal tardaría 20 minutos en llegar a Marte.
luego el rover podría ir a la izquierda,
y luego tardará otros 20 minutos antes de que pueda decirme,
"Sí, fui a la izquierda".
Debido a la distancia,
rovers y robots
van a tener que trabajar de manera autónoma.
El único problema con esto
es que las misiones a Marte son altamente riesgosas.
Lo hemos visto hace unas semanas.
¿Y si la mitad de la misión no llega a Marte?
¿Qué hacemos?
Bueno, en lugar de construir solo uno o dos rovers
como lo hicimos en la Luna,
vamos a construir cientos de ellos.
Parece un montículo de termitas, ¿no?
Si llevara la mitad de la colonia de termitas,
aún podrían construir el montículo.
Puede llevar un poco más de tiempo.
Esto es lo mismo.
Si la mitad de los rovers o los robots no llegan,
llevará un poco más de tiempo, pero aún se podrá hacer.
Aquí tenemos incluso tres rovers diferentes.
Atrás, ven la excavadora.
Es muy buena para cavar regolito.
Luego tenemos el transportador,
genial para tomar regolito y llevarlo a la estructura.
Y los últimos, los pequeños con patitas,
no necesitan moverse mucho:
se asientan en una capa de regolito
y lo cocinan con microondas,
y capa por capa crean esa estructura de domo.
Ahora...
también queremos probarlo,
así que salimos en un viaje por carretera,
y creamos nuestro propio enjambre de robots.
Ahí lo tienen.
Construimos 10 robots. Es un pequeño enjambre.
Y tomamos seis toneladas de arena,
y probamos cómo estos pequeños robots
podrían mover esa arena,
arena terrestre en este caso.
Y no fueron teleoperados, ¿sí?
Nadie indicó ir a la izquierda, a la derecha, ni dio un camino predeterminado.
No. Les dieron una tarea:
mover arena de esta zona a esa zona.
Y si se encontraban un obstáculo, como una roca,
tenían que sortearlo por su cuenta.
O si se encontraban con otro robot,
tenían que poder tomar decisiones.
O incluso si la mitad se caía, o se agotaban sus baterías,
aún tenían que poder terminar esa tarea.
Ya he hablado de redundancia.
Pero eso no fue solo con los robots.
Fue también con los hábitats.
En el proyecto de Marte decidimos hacer tres domos
porque, si uno no llegaba,
los otros dos aún podrían formar una base,
y eso fue principalmente porque cada uno de los domos
en realidad, tiene un sistema de soporte de la vida construido en el piso,
que puede operar de forma independiente.
De alguna manera, podrían pensar, bueno, esto es bastante loco.
¿Por qué Ud., como arquitecto, se involucró con el espacio?
Porque es un campo muy técnico.
Bueno, en realidad estoy muy convencido
de que desde una mirada creativa o una mirada de diseño,
uno puede resolver problemas muy difíciles que tienen muchas limitaciones.
Y realmente siento que hay un lugar para el diseño y la arquitectura
en proyectos para habitar otros cuerpos celestes.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)